hallo liebe leute hier sind man se und
kari mittlerweile ist die dritte woche
von unserer usa-reise angebrochen und
unser road trip hat begonnen
ihr habt schon zwei episoden gesehen aus
new york und washington dc wo wir
deutsche interviewt haben jetzt sind wir
unterwegs im südwesten der usa
und wir werden für euch von der straße
berichten wurde herfahren und werden mit
euch über die unterschiede zwischen
deutschland und den usa reden
los gehts oder
ja wir sind jetzt gerade auf dem weg
nach las vegas heute nacht wärme im
monument valley wir sind seit sieben
stunden unterwegs
garmisch ist gerade aufgewacht fängt
jetzt gern gitarre zu spielen und ich
sie du bist gut drauf oder
unsere erste station ist jetzt der horse
shoe band richtigen entfernt schon ganz
schwummrig gewonnen wir fangen an mit
den top drei der großen überraschungen
easy was hat dich am meisten überrascht
in amerika deine nummer drei nummer drei
wäre glaube ich dass es erstmal so
riesige wohnmobile und die ziehen
dahinter immer so ein kleines auto mit
das fand ich sehr überraschend für mich
im sehr viele lösungen im badezimmer die
super angenehm sind zum beispiel unter
der dusche was du einfach zwei
bewegungen zack zack und schon wenn du
die position kennt ist das eine bewegung
zack und schon läuft das wasser was du
zumindest während und dem 25 knapp das
gehäuse angenehm ist sehr leise und sehe
ich will das gar nicht beschreiben weil
es vielleicht überflüssig ist aber immer
auch die die wasserhähne sind so gemacht
dass man nun mit eine bewegung des
wassers laufendes ich fand dass ich
weiter meine neue angenehm danke jungs
meine nummer eins der größten
überraschung in amerika ist no network
coverage wir fahren hier durch die
gegend und nirgends wo hat man netz und
da frage ich mich wirklich wie kann es
sein dass in einem der entwickelten und
modernsten länder der welt gibt es dirks
wo scheiß handynetz das geht und wie
auch im nirgendwo
ich habe hier jetzt hier gerade seit
drei tagen zum ersten mal netz hier im
nirgendwo er aber sonst selbst in
washington dc hatte ich kein netz mit
t-mobile- und du hast ihn hat auch wenn
es das ist ja krass weiter geht's okay
im casino ist der große traum
wahrgeworden
für uns was auch ganz interessant zu
sehen aber wir haben da einer verlorenen
ich hätte vorher poker noch einmal nicht
erinnern sollen wie das geht dann hätte
ich vielleicht nicht 50 dollar
verdoppelt jetzt gerade und jochen
wegner l und ich finde dass nach selbst
real das jetzt plötzlich in kalifornien
unseren dritten viel zu schnell hinter
sind wir woanders
frau gestern waren noch in der
gemeinsamen in den westen
palmen
die leute mittlerweile sind wir in los
angeles angekommen und wir haben hier
ein easyjet hat sehr viele leute sind
gekommen und zufällig haben wir auch wie
man auf deutschland trafen ganze rudolph
ist schauspielerin hier was machst du
hier
ich bin seit drei jahren hier habt
schauspiel studiert und fangen langsam
an zu arbeiten ist das schwierig sich
als deutsche schauspielerin hier
durchzusetzen
ja auf jeden fall also man wird viel
gefragt auch reform woher kommst du und
man muss halt den akzent auf jeden fall
loswerden weil es wird man nur noch auf
die deutsche reduziert und das will man
natürlich schon sehr liebe leute gestern
morgen sind wir in allen losverfahren
haben einen zwischenstopp in 20 jahren
gemacht und jetzt sind wir auch den weg
nach san francisco an dieser
wunderschönen straße und wir dachten wir
mal einfach mal ein video für euch im
regen auf dem auf die straße nach san
francisco unser thema ist jetzt was
magst du an den usa
da haben uns gutes wetter ausgesucht die
sie was ist deine nummer 2 was mag sonne
usa meine nummer zwei sind die netten
menschen alle sind sehr offen und
freundlich zu uns und anderen
wahrscheinlich auch und es ist
tatsächlich sind hier alle sehr gut
drauf positive art locker bei nummer
zwei ist die wunderschöne landschaft
guckt euch mal hier um natürlich würde
es schöner aussehen wenn die sonne
scheint aber es ist trotzdem wunderschön
und was mich überrascht ist einfach
diese vielfalt der landschaft und es
erinnert mich mehr an südafrika als in
europa die ganze landschaft aber auch so
ein paar kleinigkeiten wie die
tankstellen und die stopps und so was
ist deine nummer eins ist wir haben eine
nummer eins ist witziger weise die weite
die natur wie weit alles ist also man
hat sehr viel
jetzt sind wir an bergen hat total
blicke über weite landschaften und
gleich liebe draußen zu seinen natur ist
es hier genialer im rathaus nummer eins
die menschen ja ich weiß das ist schon
ein bisschen
das sagen alle ja die ganze zeit aber es
ist wirklich so ist es so cool gäste am
saßen wir draußen am meer
und dann kam typ vorbei und hat uns
einfach irgendwie eine halbe stunde eine
geschichte erzählt und davor habe ich
ein
tankstelle gehalten da kam typ an ich
habe mich um rat gefragt wegen einer
liebesgeschichte und ich rede einfach
ich mag das gerne irgendwo rein zu gehen
um mit menschen zu reden was schön
weiter geht
die
ergibt
aufhört zu regnen
dafür sind wir jetzt am strand wir
machen jetzt die top 2 der sachen die
uns nicht gefallen an den usa sie was
ist deine nummer zwei meine nummer zwei
ist dass es keinen guten kaffee gibt
heute irgendwo mal guten kaffee aber wir
haben auch kein gefunden und viele
amerikaner dass auch stetig die auch mal
in deutschland waren in deutschland
finde es an jeder ecke sogar eine
kaffeerösterei und hier findet man
einfach keinen guten kaffee und ich weiß
nicht warum die leute starbucks mögen in
deutschland geht also ich genieße
starbucks war das eine kette ist aber
hier hat sarasin besten kaffee weil es
gibt keinen guten kaffee also ich habe
lange nachgedacht und ehrlich gesagt ich
habe weder die nummer 2 0 noch die
nummer eins ich finde nichts was mir in
amerika und was typisch amerikanischen
massivem was mir nicht gefällt weil
eigentlich gefällt mir gefällt mir alles
und das was mir nicht gefällt ist nicht
typisch amerikanisch sondern ist halt
eben schlecht her und wann das genau so
bleibst du dich bei den zuschauern ein
gar nicht aber ich bin bekannterweise
sehr freuen
mai nummer zwei ist plastik plastik müll
also über einiges plastik es gibt in
plastiktüten in supermärkten immer man
muss sie mitnehmen ist die plastik
besteck überall in den schulen wo wir
waren haben wir plastikbesteck bekommen
in den hotels urbanen wird zum teil von
plastik gegessen und alles wird zehn
minuten benutzt und weggeschmissen
das will ich nicht gut ist was ist denn
deine nummer eins was magst du gar nicht
in amerika mein name ist an nummer zwei
plastik plastik styropor alles
weggeworfen
nein wer und was deine nummer eins immer
noch nicht schweigt du war eben hast du
das schon gesagt demba du hast ja
gemeint okay das ist jetzt nicht sehr
typisch amerikanisches vielleicht
typisch
menschlich gebrechlich menschliche meine
nummer eins ist die distanzen
wobei das ja nicht zwingend eine schuld
von irgendwem ist aber in manchen
städten frage ich mich warum die so weit
auseinander gebaut sind
dann gibt es ein riesengelände da ist
dann ein geschäft und dann gibt es ein
riesengelände ist noch ein geschäft und
man muss immer im auto hinfahren und
gerade in den städten so die geplant
sind wie geplant angelegt wurden
würde mich das stören wenn ich leben
würde ich finde es jetzt nicht total
schlecht aber ich mag das dass ich zu
hause in berlin zu fuß einem fahrrad
über hinfahren kann weil das macht mich
irgendwie unabhängiger und das war's vom
strand weiter geht's auf die straße
und das ist unser letztes thema für
diese folge und zwar das thema ist
missverständnisse missverständnis
unseren thema janisch aus essen mit
hast du sind die missverständnisse
aufgefallen hier in den usa was sind die
größten missstände zwischen usa und
deutschland ich weiß nicht was die
größten sind aber heute morgen waren wir
einkaufen und wir standen in der
schlange zu der kasse und eine zweite
kasse hat aufgemacht und wir wie es wie
wir es aus deutschland kennen uns
schnell an die zweite klasse
angeschmissen und dann hat die
kassiererin aber gesagt nein nein
der mensch dort ist quasi der nächste
und dann ist mir klar geworden ach ja
sowohl in england als in amerika stellt
man sich an die schlange an und man
respektiert das auch nicht wie die
deutschen einfach vordringen
ja die leute als erstes land hat
gewonnen
das ist ein missverständnis sein top
missverständnis zwischen deutschen und
amerikanern
ich habe leider kein richtig ich habe
meine gedanken gemacht aber so richtig
mit 1 passiert da paar sachen haben wir
schon bei überraschungen vor genannt
aber ein richtiges messerstecher ist mir
noch nicht passiert
also was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe war
so deutsche ich glaube also ein das eine
ist diese dass das amerika so groß ist
ich glaube dass viele deutsche nicht
checken wirklich dass in deutschland
denkt man so ja amerika ist ein land und
alle amerikaner sind mehr oder weniger
gleich aber eben es gibt in den usa viel
viel viel viel mehr unterschiede als in
deutschland zwischen nord und süd zum
beispiel und das zweite was ich denke
ist dass wir amerika sind schön kennen
soll
ich glaube wir haben so ein
idealisiertes amerikabild oder manchmal
auch ein übertrieben schlecht ist aber
das ist halt eben nicht die realität und
wenn man nicht selber in die uns erfährt
versteht man das halt nicht wie das
aussieht genau denke ich auch amerika
ist ganz ähnlich wie afrikas ein ganzes
kontinent
besteht aus 51 ländern sie sind auch
sehr unterschiedlich und so kann man
auch am möglichkeit verstehen und
diensten mit vorsicht und genau gucken
ja kontinent kommt noch ein paarmal es
ist ein kontinent aber es ist so groß
wie konnte das willi anstatt es ist so
man könnte die usa mit europa
vergleichen und nicht mit einem land das
ist meine ja genau
kohl wir sind hier jetzt eine schöne
kulisse von full house dieser serie die
wir als kinder geguckt haben wir sind
total begeistert sieht es aus wie in
echt ja er wir haben erst gedacht
vielleicht ist es ja dass sein dass da
hinten und dann saß aber nur so ähnlich
auf und dann kam mir noch waren uns
sicher das ist der blick kennt er von
haus kennt ihr voraus wenn ihr es kennt
schreibt uns mal wir sind gespannt wer
das noch als kind geguckt hat das auf
jeden fall hat mein amerika bild geprägt
bis gleich
das war unsere episode für heute während
an der letzte station unserer reise
angekommen in san francisco bestehen vor
der golden gate bridge
passenderweise ist die brücke im nebel
versunken
von hier fahren wir noch einmal wieder
zurück in den süden wird verbringen nach
drei tagen in santa barbara
da werdet ihr noch eine episode nächste
woche sehen über das campusleben hat sie
gefragt wie sie ja wunderschön
unglaublich wir haben zwar ist dein
erster seine erste reise nach amerika es
war wunderbar wirklich wirklich
wunderbar sehr schön wir hoffentlich hat
dieses sicher gefallen würde ich nicht
sagen aber allen bedanken die uns bei
dieser reise unterstützt haben ihr habt
uns etwas unglaublich ist ermöglicht
dafür unseren dank und unsere verneigung
wenn ihr lust habt ihr alle anderen
mittel einzuwerben
wir freuen uns über eure unterstützung
der mitarbeiter sie gerne machen
und bis nächste woche ins tante warburg